welcome to this video playing a swap
again the National monster Miller from
Germany my tias Milla there are probably
more Miller's ja that then i am even i'm
not quite sure okay we got them the
Scotch opening and I can't resist of
course to play my queen queen edge from
22 is the critical response Knight f6 h
three years so one point can also play
97 let's see what he's doing
I don't have a good score against the
sky minus one despite the substantial
rating difference now if I've the snide
g4 so this is not a problem mmm my g
form or not you have this mmm it I don't
know what I mean of course if he lets me
do it I'll give a maid on f2 but what I
want to do is to get the knight to e5
this is the real point of it like that
then maybe even Bishop g4
so Bishop g4 yeah who came that porno
they might move the airport can I do
something like can't play something like
g5 secure the night okay it's a bit
that's a bit ambitious I know but let's
let's try yeah when I say it's a bit
ambitious this is maybe one of those
famous last words moments I have an idea
and then this is the the start of
something really wacky mmm yeah Bishop
here to a for sure what the student this
is doing ok I'm not going to castle
anyway so let's uh let's continue with
this if he goes Knight f3 now I can't
even donate a queen age five because the
Queen only two is not is not protected
yeah there are some some small technical
tricks here yeah man work g 6 h
successor crew does even even too
friendly for that ok let's say let's say
you place night f3 what am i doing
against it may be Queen f4 I am simply
but ok this les roches 6 it's the
logical follow-up to my plane no use in
doing doing anything else it's not like
I don't don't really see a director of
you tation of it ok so here ya know now
I have the Queen established on e5 and I
have possible look aged 6 coming now
that's not so bad i mean the Queen only
five is a really nice piece and what
exactly is his play Queen maybe you can
attack c6 that's the only apparent
weakness him
it may be wants to play Queen g32 to
stop the screwed meeting idea
also I would the country would be four
they get this check i go king is seven
now officially six I can also get the
King to g7 which is an idea okay if I
play here he's going to play the should
be five I see okay Bishop d5 i can let
him take and recapture with the bond
you
not really sure that I'm threatening
something here but they're gaining
gaining some space as well yeah this is
some of course person Queen takes hmm I
didn't really appreciate that
Wow ah this is bad hmm I just needed one
prep move flag would be six or so to
make this far less threatening but
that's just as bad if he takes going to
take a seven
this was badly played I think it was
really unclear before that no I'm in big
trouble I'm in really big trouble yeah
okay I need counterplay who cares about
yet another porn if he takes now I have
queen d 4 at the end this is really
really pretty plain I'm also check in oh
we can give you can play with Queen be a
check for us to that time when a
terrible Oh didn't do that check maybe
maybe there's some counter play
11 seconds left check check check nice
is yes low white forfeits on time for
Jerry Scheff very very very very
complicated stuff the problem was that I
really before I ignored we need not this
idea I had at one point I had seen it
but then I forgot about it and I need to
do some precaution against that maybe
even rugby 60 but that's not what I want
to play this is just bad i mean i can
also deal with the king this would also
be would also be better so that before
it's not not so dangerous i can can even
answer that yeah there it very tough to
analyze I mean I played it in a very
provocative way to to stay up some some
fight and even this is debatable you
don't need to do that maybe maybe it was
a bad idea this allowed the whole sea
for business after all and it's not
necessary
yeah I mean okay if I just want to be
equal I can probably play move like that
23 and and trade the compounds to play
that giving why the clear advantage hmm
it's not a very human move yeah but
maybe maybe it's tough it's tough to
tough to judge i mean this is maybe then
bad it gives a why too many points to
attack should probably stay put with the
with a simple moves alright thanks for
watching